Traduttore: Monica Poli
Revisore: Federico Pepe
Buonasera.
È un grandissimo piacere
essere per me qui.
Ho sentito
delle storie bellissime,
ma voglio provare
a raccontarvi anche io
una delle mille visioni
di un futuro possibile,
il futuro che
stiamo cercando di raccontare
tutti, questa sera, qui.
Parto con una storia,
con la mia esperienza:
Da ragazzo anch'io,
come alcune delle storie
che abbiamo sentito,
ero particolarmente appassionato
all'informatica
e avevo una visione chiara
del mio futuro:
avrei fatto qualcosa
che c'entrava con i computer.
E allora da ragazzo
alle scuole superiori
avevo soltanto
un grandissimo problema:
mio padre non voleva
assolutamente
comprarmi un computer,
perché pensava che
non sarei andato poi bene a scuola,
non avrei studiato,
mi sarei messo a giocare.
E allora, a scuola coglievo
tutte le occasioni possibili
per andare nell'aula di informatica
e con la complicità
del mio professore
di matematica e fisica
stavamo insieme, sperimentavamo,
lavoravamo al computer
e io ero felicissimo.
Spesso veniva a chiamarmi
anche durante altre lezioni
bussava, diceva:
"Collega, mi serve Antonio
per un progetto didattico"
e io felicissimo andavo con lui.
Cosa facevamo insieme?
Costruivamo una BBS.
Era un sistema che faceva
parlare i computer tra di loro
collegandoli con un modem
e così le persone potevano
scambiarsi documenti, informazioni,
programmi scolastici.
Era bellissimo, l'abbiamo fatta
proprio bene insieme!
Però, nuovo problema: è successo che
non si collegava nessuno.
Perché era troppo presto.
I miei compagni non avevano
ancora il modem a casa.
E così, un primo grande insegnamento:
non c'è un'innovazione senza condivisione.
È inutile andare avanti troppo presto
se poi gli altri non sono con te.
Allora abbiamo comprato con dei soldi
della scuola dieci di questi modem.
Li abbiamo portati in biblioteca
e cosi speravamo che
quando i ragazzi andassero
a prendere un libro
potevano anche portare a casa
per una settimana il modem.
Questo è successo.
Il nostro esperimento
andò molto bene.
Eravamo contenti.
Ma di lì a poco Internet
avrebbe cambiato tutto.
Quindi questo lavoro che
avevamo fatto,
lo abbiamo subito trasformato.
Abbiamo fatto il nostro sito
e facevamo le cose lì.
Io sono andato più avanti.
Ho cominciato a lavorarci con Internet:
a fare un mio sito,
a provare a fare i siti degli altri,
a comprare dagli Stati Uniti
e rivendere qui in Italia.
Si stava un po' verificando
quello che era il mio sogno:
lavorare con l'informatica.
E infatti il quinto anno delle superiori,
vado da mio padre e gli dico:
"Sai, devo aprire la partita IVA,
perché ho dei clienti" e lui dice:
"ma sei assolutamente pazzo;
finisci il tuo percorso di studi e
se otterrai il massimo dei voti
apriremo la partita IVA".
Lo faccio. Succede. Ci riesco.
E da questo mix tra sfida,
merito, ma soprattutto passione,
un professore mentor e
un'ambiente favorevole, la scuola
sono diventato imprenditore.
La scuola mi ha fornito un'occasione,
ma tutto il resto
ho dovuto impararlo da solo.
Le competenze per fare un'impresa
purtroppo oggi la scuola non le da.
Io credo che, nel nostro futuro,
ci sarà molta più impresa a scuola
e molta più scuola nell'impresa.
Questi due mondi si devono
parlare assolutamente bene.
E', forse per il mio percorso,
che da sempre ho cercato di aiutare
le scuole a diffondere la cultura
dell'impresa e dell'imprenditorialità
e mi sono spinto anche
un po' più avanti
diventando Business Angel,
e quindi aiutando le startup,
investendo e supportandole
per provare a non farle fare
gli errori che avevo fatto io
Si, perché, vedete,
sento troppo spesso una frase:
i giovani sono il futuro.
Io non credo che i giovani sono il futuro.
Io credo che sono il presente.
Noi non dobbiamo aiutare i giovani
a trovare una loro strada,
noi dobbiamo costruire
questa strada insieme con loro.
Una strada che peraltro
non serve solo ai giovani,
ma serve a tutti.
E proprio sul tema di giovani e futuro
voglio raccontarvi
una seconda storia,
una seconda esperienza.
Stavolta non un'esperienza individuale,
che riguardava me,
il mio sogno, la mia azienda
ma una esperienza collettiva.
Qualche anno fa mi sono
avvicinato all'associazionismo,
sentivo il bisogno di confrontarmi
con i colleghi imprenditori
e ho, diciamo, trovato questo stimolo
in Confindustria.
Dopo poco tempo
ne sono diventato il presidente.
E sapete quando ci si presenta,
no, a un elettorato,
bisogna presentare un programma.
Solitamente è un passaggio formale.
Invece noi abbiamo voluto dargli
un grande significato.
Abbiamo riflettuto tanto
sul futuro della nostra città.
Cosa potevamo fare noi, da imprenditori,
giovani, per la nostra città?
E quindi, abbiamo cominciato
a pensare che
la nostra città poteva fare
il tifo per chi fa impresa.
Doveva fare il tifo per chi fa impresa.
Volevamo costruire un ecosistema
favorevole a chi volesse intraprendere,
dove le opportunità
possono circolare veloci,
essere colte dai giovani.
Pensavamo a un nuovo
paradigma economico per Catania.
Ci voleva un modo semplice per dirlo
e abbiamo coniato questa formula.
Noi volevamo che la nostra città
diventasse una startup city
e quindi la formula è
giovani + territorio = sviluppo.
Bella la formula, efficace.
Bisognava metterla in pratica
ed è bastata la nostra prima
presentazione in pubblico
il nostro primo progetto, lo sportello
per la creazione d'impesa
ed è successa
una cosa straordinaria.
Le forze della città, le forze attive,
vive, si sono avvicinate
e ci hanno detto:
"Ci piace questo progetto,
facciamolo insieme".
E allora altri giovani,
associazioni, startup,
istituzioni, enti, mondo universitario,
insieme abbiamo trasformato
un progetto
che era di una parte della città
in un progetto molto più vasto.
Il progetto della Startup City.
Decine di eventi in questi anni,
progetti, network,
supporto alle idee
che volevano nascere, competenze.
E' stato ed è un percorso meraviglioso.
Un percorso che
ci fa ottenere grandi risultati,
perché la cosa bella
di un percorso di comunità,
è che questi risultati
si possono monitorare.
Nuove aziende che si sono aperte,
nuovi posti di lavoro che si sono creati,
tanta effervescenza
ed entusiasmo in città.
E anche, il momento in cui
un grande player nazionale
come Working Capital ha scelto
una città nel mezzogiorno
per aprire l'acceleratore,
una casa dell'innovazione,
ha scelto la nostra Catania.
E' stato davvero
un percorso bellissimo.
E credo che nel nostro futuro,
queste comunità,
quelle che i nostri amici di Rena chiamano
le comunità del cambiamento
avranno un ruolo
sempre più importante.
Credo che le persone,
unendo le loro passioni,
le loro competenze,
la loro voglia di cambiare le cose,
con semplicità, potranno fare tantissimo.
E credo che una delle storie che
potremo raccontare molto presto
sarà quando queste community
cercheranno
di essere più forti insieme
e provare a crescere
costantemente insieme,
e andare avanti.
E quindi, vi ho voluto
raccontare queste due storie,
per raccontarvi
come immagino il futuro.
C'è però un'ultima cosa che devo dirvi.
Lo avrete notato, no?
C'è una palla qui, che per noi
ha un valore molto importante
perché questa palla è il simbolo
della nostra community,
ed è l'elemento totemico
che racconta questa frase,
questa bellissima frase di John Cage:
"Nothing is a mistake.
There's no win and no fail,
there's only make".
Questa è tutta la sintesi
di quello che vi ho detto finora.
Il futuro lo possiamo immaginare,
possiamo sperare di raggiungerlo,
ma soprattutto ci dobbiamo lavorare,
da subito.
E ci dobbiamo lavorare insieme.
Nel basket se entro trenta secondi
l'azione non è finita,
la palla passa all'altra squadra.
Purtroppo nella nostra cultura,
se pensiamo al nostro sport
più diffuso, il calcio,
possiamo anche vedere
una partita di 90 minuti
e non si segna neanche un gol.
No? Finisce a 0-0.
Sono due approcci completamente diversi.
Noi siamo per l'approccio del fare.
Quindi in acceleratore,
o quando facciamo degli eventi,
c'è sempre una palla che simboleggia
questa azione, questa responsabilità.
Chi parla ce l'ha in mano.
Che poi col gesto più semplice possibile,
lo diciamo anche come luogo comune,
ti passo la palla,
ma noi la passiamo fisicamente.
E la responsabilità dell'azione
passa a un'altra persona.
Io credo che, oggi, qui,
non ci siano soltanto mille persone,
quello che vedo io sono
mille visioni di un futuro possibile.
E allora io questa partita del futuro
vorrei provare a giocarla con voi.
E vorrei provare come faccio
da me a passare la palla.
Ora non vedo bene, ma ci proverò.
C'è una persona
che dovrebbe riceverla.
E vi dico perché voglio giocare
questa partita con voi:
perché, come dice
il mio amico Riccardo Luna,
nel futuro, o ci andiamo tutti
o non ci va nessuno.
A voi la palla.
(Applausi)
Grazie.